Усе життя він мріяв літати, дивлячись на птахів.
Лукас Гайм уже багато разів переглянув відеозаписи практичних занять пілотів "Люфтганзи" у Сполучених Штатах.
Власне, 22-річний юнак вже сам мав би сидіти за штурвалом.
Уже понад рік, як він почав втілювати свою заповітну мрію у льотній школі в Бремені.
Однак тепер замість того, щоб літати, він мусить спаковувати речі - разом зі своєю подругою.
У березні Lufthansa зупинила вишкіл пілотів.
Близько 700 молодих людей опинились у підвішеному стані.
Це перекреслило плани й Лукасу.
Мене весь час втішали. То казали, що навчання відновиться у травні, то у вересні, то наступного року в січні.
І оскільки ця перспектива для нас така невизначена, то настав час припинити оренду квартири.
Скільки можна платити орендну плату?
Це означає, що цей етап нашого спільного життя у Бремені -
колия мав стати пілотом, а вона хотіла розпочати навчання - поки що позаду.
Лукас та його подруга Свея терпляче чекали півроку.
Але рано чи пізно треба було щось вирішувати.
Ми їхали сюди із чітким планом. Аби він міг закінчити тут своє навчання.
І тепер ми повертаємося, не завершивши навчання.
Мені це нагадує марафонський забіг, під час якого ти розвертаєшся посередині, не добігаючи до цілі.
Найбільша авіакомпанія Німеччини Lufthansa унаслідок пандемії коронавірусу опинилася на межі банкрутства.
Лише завдяки державній підтримці у розмірі 9 мільярдів євро вдалося врятувати концерн.
Добра половина літаків усе ще залишається на землі.
Керівник льотних шкіл "Люфтганзи" - Штефан-Кенан Шайб - каже, що вже зараз в авіакомпанії на тисячу пілотів більше, ніж їй потрібно.
Ми відверто кажемо студентам пілотних шкіл про їхнє майбутнє.
Наразі ці перспективи дуже й дуже погані. Через пандемію та економічне становище концерну Lufthansa.
Щомісяця ми втрачаємо 500 мільйонів євро і відчуваємо, що повинні казати студентам про це максимально відверто.
Робочі місця за штурвалом будуть у дефіциті і після пандемії.
Поступове одужання авіаційної галузі фахівці прогнозують не раніше 2025 року.
Для студентів-пілотів це означає, що гроші їм доведеться заробляти в іншому місці, аби звести кінці з кінцями.
Каролін Бьознер звістка про скасування навчання застала у США.
27-річна німкеня тепер мешкає знову зі своїми батьками у Лейпцигу.
Та працює в логістичному центрі Amazon.
Це справді було нелегко. Але ухвалене рішення було цілком прагматичним.
Тому що я знала, що не можу сидіти без діла, треба чимось займатися.
Непогано б і заробляти гроші. Адже студент-пілот грошей не заробляє. Радше навпаки витрачає.
Мало у кого зі студентів-пілотів є фінансові резерви. Ось чому більшість з них опинилися в такій скруті.
Коли почалася пандемія, студенти на кшталт Кароліни були не єдиними, кому швидко знадобилася нова робота.
До нас зверталися люди з туристичної галузі, з гастрономії.
Серед них були й ті, хто шукав тимчасової роботи, і ті, хто вирішив повністю перепланувати своє життя.
Для Каролін Бьознер робота на Amazon - лише тимчасове рішення, каже вона.
Тому що багато років свого життя вона присвятила тому, аби стати пілотесою.
Я не полишаю цю мрію. Я обов'язково мушу літати. Це бажання глибоков моєму серці і ніколи не покине мене.
Я облетіла усю Флориду, це залишило надзвичайно приємні враження. І раптом опинилася знову в холодній Німеччині.
Просто не можу собі уявити іншого заняття.
Відповідно, треба щось придумати, як зробити так, щоб завершити цей план - у крайньому разі без "Люфтганзи".
"Люфтганза" запропонувала студентам перервати навчання.
В іншому разі їм довелося б заплатити за освіту 80 тисяч євро. Не отримавши при цьому гарантії роботи.
Батько Лукаса не знаходить слів, щоб описати свої емоції. Він сам працює пілотом "Люфтганзи" вже 32 роки.
Мені спадає на думку слово "примушення". Тобто якщо я відмовлюся і підпишу угоду про скасування навчання, тоді все буде добре.
А якщо я хочу втілити свою мрію, тоді від тебе вимагають дуже багато грошей.
Мені це не подобається. Я вважаю, це нечесно.
Порожні коридори та аудиторії Європейської льотної школи у Бремені справляють гнітюче враження на Лукаса.
Він не був тут уже більше 8 місяців.
Незважаючи на скрутні обставини, Лукас все ж збирається обов'язково втілити свою мрію. Навіть якщо ще не знає, як саме.
Я би хотів, аби нам сказали, можливо, щось на кшталт: якщо знову будемо проводити набір студентів, тоді ви станете тим, кого ми візьмемо.
Або принаймні щоби були визнані результати наших іспитів.
Однак такої обіцянки не дають.
І навіть голова правління "Люфтганзи" не може обнадіяти студентів.
Уже нині в нього немає роботи для 30 тисяч співробітників.
Як і в решті професій, на які треба вчитися, як і в усіх німецьких університетах, ніде немає гарантії на майбутню роботу.
І в нас так буде. Звісно, авіація залишається дуже захопливою галуззю, в тому числі для молоді.
Однак я вважаю, що треба дивитися в очі реальності: у наступні роки в авіації буде надто мало робочих місць для надто багатьох працівників.
І кожен, хто оцінює свої професійні перспективи, має зважати на це.
Коронавірус може перекреслити заповітну мрію про польоти багатьом пілотам-початківцям.